okay so amongst the younger generation
not only can we not listen to
Alternative points of view and do we
believe in these woke nonsense um women
nowadays are than ever it is
actually crazy Annie a 26-year-old
content creator from Australia's Gold
Coast shared her experience with the
Kyle and and Jackie show discussing her
active sex life as empowering she
claimed to have engaged in sexual
encounters with over 300 people in a
year finding it exciting and imp EMP
powering emphasizing that sex is meant
to make you feel good she used dating
apps and her only fans page to find
Partners reportedly earning $1,000 daily
from only fans where she's in the top 4%
of content creators Annie has eight
regular Annie has eight regular partners
and is comfortable with both men and
women sexually I'm sure she is Jesus